are we at a point now i was talking
yesterday about uh public company ceos
who do not
address the cash and cash equivalents
being 100 their balance sheet are they
violating the fiduciary duty i think so
i mean that's what i wrote yesterday i
look this is not just a bill pumping
bitcoin thing
put bitcoin aside for a second if you
have if you're holding an asset
right if your business is growing 10 a
year which is you know what you look for
in a you know in a growth public company
and you have an asset which is losing 10
of its value a year that you're holding
your profits in well you have a problem
because you're basically doing a fred
flintstone in your car spinning your
wheels going nowhere right so what is
your responsibility at that point well
it's probably either to grow the value
of your treasury invest it in something
that has higher growth than you know
what you're doing with it which is
nothing or give it back to your
shareholders and of course they don't
want to give it back to the shareholders
they want to buy more shares ultimately
to make themselves richer that's part of
the problem right is is they they just
go back to the easy solution which is uh
we'll just buy back the shares make
ourselves richer and when the stock
price goes up everybody looks good short
term
we're in this interesting mode where one
of these rare scenarios where for the
next few months everything you own is
going to go up
including bonds by the way right so even
though it's trash i think bond market is
going to go up for for probably a few
weeks maybe even a few months and and
then it's going to revert back to the
mean which is [ __ ]
and and at that point you know i don't
know if if if it's going to happen in 22
that the fixed income markets really
start to think about okay you know we
need to basically enable riaas and
others to own to own uh bitcoin and to
replace the 40 percent or if people and
companies just do it on their own we'll
see yeah it's
fascinating when you start to think
about um
you're basically going to get
not just drop gold buy bitcoin you're
going to get dropped bonds by bitcoin
100 you're gonna get dropped like all
the trash assets that are sitting there
that's it and part of it we were just
talking about like these public pension
funds that are essentially locked into
these investment mandates or these asset
allocations
they got a lot of work to do because
they're gonna go change the investment
mandate they gotta educate their uh you
know their board and there's a lot of
people who hey don't rock the boat here
right like like let's not get fired
let's not kind of screw up a good thing
this has been great to us but they're
looking at the past historical analysis
they're not necessarily looking at the
current environment yeah and they're
also not even like close to this
discussion yet yeah there's a lot of
people in that world and i used to work
in fixed income that don't even follow
what we're talking about yet all that
means is is from a contrarian investor
perspective there's nobody on the bus
and when you have conviction for an
investment and there's nobody else on
the bus that's when you should be the
most excited yeah so we we who are in
the middle of this think that it's like
late in the game it is not
when you look i mean the game is just
starting from from a macro perspective
right yeah and and that's why i think
folks like you know ralph paul are so
excited because they understand the rest
of these global markets that have no
effing clue about what's going on in our
world they're just starting to see that
hey this thing's worth two trillion
dollars what's going on yep right that's
the beginning of the game all right
before we bring kevin o'leary on tell us
real quick about abra kind of what uh
you guys are doing right now i know you
guys have made a bunch of progress
raised more money and assets seem to be
going up yeah we just closed our series
c 40 million um we are managing well
over a billion now
uh in re it's all retail which is really
hard and we have a developing markets
business which is killing it we actually
really unique in that we service very
high net worth clients in the us and in
europe we also have a developing markets
business in asia and central america all
exactly the same product you know buying
and trading crypto bitcoin ethereum
bunch of other cryptos uh the ability to
earn yield we just launched cardano
yesterday so you can earn interest on
bitcoin ethereum cardano eight percent
on dollars we also launched uh announced
the new token program um we partnered
with a new group out of switzerland
called the crypto banking alliance it's
going to be kind of a quasi education
lobbying organization to help promote uh
d5 bitcoin ethereum within the banking
system and they have a rewards token
they've launched and and they're giving
30 of that to our customers as a reward
for you know using abra and then other
companies will be able to apply to
grants from from that alliance we have
no ownership in it i have no oversight
of it it'll basically do grants to
whoever qualifies
and uh yeah we've got a bunch of other
products after that coming out so our
lending product which we announced in
march is now live in like 44 45 states
in the u.s and 50 countries that's been
our fastest growing product the last few
months um and we're pr every product we
have has been profitable for the company
and we've been profitable for about a
year now and probably 10x the revenue
over the last year or so